-A regarder trop d'écrans
à votre âge,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
-On a mal aux yeux.
Tu as raison.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe d'autre ?
-On a...
Notre cerveau,
il comprend rien.
-Oui, car dans votre cerveau,
il y a beaucoup de choses.
Au bout d'un moment,
il ne comprend plus trop
et ne retient plus
les choses.
Musique douce
...
Je suis Caroline Janvier,
députée Renaissance
de la deuxième circonscription
du Loiret.
Je travaille
sur la surexposition
aux écrans
des enfants.
Les enfants de 0 à 2 ans passent,
en moyenne,
3h11 par jour
devant un écran.
Ca a un effet
sur les apprentissages scolaires,
notamment.
Voilà,
c'est mon combat.
Musique dansante
...
-Ce jour-là, à Orléans,
dans une école maternelle
de sa circonscription,
Caroline Janvier assiste
à une séance
de sensibilisation
aux écrans.
-Là, je vous ai mis
des affiches avec des situations
et une famille qui utilise
beaucoup les écrans.
Ils se parlent entre eux ?
-NON.
-Ils font des choses ensemble ?
-Le plus petit fait quoi ?
Il s'endort devant la télé.
En plus,
c'est peut-être pas adapté
à son âge.
-Il a l'air fatigué.
Vous avez vu ?
-Si ça se trouve, en plus,
il devrait être au lit.
-Moi, parfois...
Je regarde
un film d'horreur.
-Ah ? Et après,
tu fais des cauchemars ?
-Oui.
Musique douce
-Des élèves de 5 ans,
déjà régulièrement exposés,
non seulement
à la télévision,
mais aussi aux tablettes,
aux smartphones.
-On se rend compte
que c'est très présent.
C'est devenu anodin.
Anodin, enfin c'est...
Les écrans,
ça fait partie de la vie.
Ca se passe
dans quelle pièce ?
-Et les conséquences
de cette exposition,
cette enseignante
les repère immédiatement.
-Ce qu'on a constaté,
c'était au niveau
de la concentration,
de la disponibilité
lors d'une activité,
qui est très, très courte...
On relie ça, justement,
à l'exposition des écrans.
-Tu voulais dire quoi ?
Tu fais des colères, parfois ?
-Oui.
Quand on éteint à la télé ?
-Oui ?
-Caroline Janvier
porte une proposition de loi
pour limiter
ces temps d'écran.
Ce n'est pas pour rien
si elle parle avant tout
aux plus jeunes.
-Plus vous êtes
un utilisateur précoce
de ces équipements-là,
plus vous serez
un utilisateur compulsif,
ou en tout cas, important.
Donc, quand on peut avoir,
à l'école,
des instituteurs
qui parlent de ça,
qui éduquent aussi
au bon usage
et au "pas trop d'usage",
ça change tout.
Musique dynamique
Cris d'enfants
-Et en primaire,
cela se confirme.
A 10 ans,
aucun de ces élèves de CM2
n'échappe aux écrans
et reconnaît même
avoir du mal à s'en passer.
-Doit-on limiter les écrans ?
-Moi, j'ai mon conseil :
essayez, à des moments,
de tout faire pour ne pas...
Enfin, s'éloigner,
poser l'écran
et aller faire autre chose
dans une autre pièce.
C'est simplement en le regardant
que t'as envie d'y jouer.
C'est comme la nourriture.
Dès que tu le vois,
t'as envie.
-Une fois, j'étais en appel
avec mes copines
et on jouait à un jeu vidéo.
On a joué trop longtemps.
-Combien de temps ? Tu sais ?
-2 heures.
-Ca agit presque
comme une drogue, finalement.
Quand on parle d'addiction,
on parle de divers types de drogue
et on se rend compte
que les écrans ont le même effet.
C'est une lutte
à mener au quotidien.
Au quotidien, à travers
les activités qu'on met en place,
notamment faire revenir la lecture
au centre des intérêts,
les activités sportives,
les activités dans la nature.
C'est autant d'outils
qui vont les aider à lutter
contre l'addiction aux écrans.
-Vous êtes formée à ça,
dans votre cursus ?
-On n'a pas de formation
particulière pour ça,
mais en tout cas,
on sait que c'est notre rôle.
On sait qu'on est
un acteur principal,
sur ce type de lutte.
-En réalité, une prévention
qui dépend trop souvent
du bon vouloir des écoles,
des professeurs,
et que Caroline Janvier
souhaite rendre systématique.
-C'est justement ce que prévoit
la loi que je porte.
C'est une formation
de tous les enseignants
du premier degré,
pour que tout le monde
soit sensibilisé
et soit équipé d'outils
pour bien faire comprendre
aux enfants
l'importance et les risques
d'une surexposition aux écrans.
-Je vote pour.
Elles rient.
-Je vous remercie !
Au revoir !
-MERCI. AU REVOIR.
-La députée veut même
aller plus loin :
former les professionnels
de la petite enfance,
les professionnels
de santé, aussi.
-Bonjour !
Bonjour, princesse !
-Une exposition précoce
peut entraîner des troubles graves
du développement de l'enfant.
-On y va ?
Allez, viens.
Vas-y. On y va.
-Cette pédiatre
a une consultation
unique en France à l'hôpital,
sur la surexposition
aux écrans.
A 3 ans,
Maya ne parle quasiment pas.
-Ca a commencé vers quel âge,
à peu près ?
Là, vous dites
vers trois mois, six mois.
-C'est allumé,
pendant les repas ?
Vous mangez avec les écrans ?
-Oui, oui, oui.
-Vous les utilisez
pour la calmer ?
-Euh... Oui.
-Elle a un examen, pour moi,
tout à fait...
-Le médecin s'appuie
sur un questionnaire spécifique
pour évaluer sa consommation
et sa dépendance aux écrans.
Résultat :
5 à 6 heures par jour.
-Ca impacte vraiment
de nombreux domaines,
que ça soit le comportement,
la gestion des humeurs,
la gestion des frustrations,
qui est importante,
quand on est petit,
et surtout l'entrée dans le langage
et les interactions.
Ouais !
Tu veux faire le docteur ?
-Des enfants sans langage cohérent
qui, comme Maya,
ne font que répéter ce qu'ils ont vu
dans les dessins animés.
-Effectivement,
les différentes applications,
comme YouTube ou autre,
vont mettre l'alphabet
en faisant croire aux parents
que c'est comme ça
qu'on va faire des progrès.
Du coup, on met
les choses à l'envers.
On apprend l'alphabet à 3 ans,
mais on ne parle pas encore bien.
Je veux que votre petite fille,
elle apprenne les mots "pull",
"chaussette", "pomme", "camion",
les mots du quotidien.
-D'accord.
-C'est sur ça
qu'il va falloir revenir
pour que le langage s'installe.
Musique légère
-Et pour cela,
le message de la pédiatre
est radical :
arrêt total des écrans.
-En fait, cette télé allumée,
quand on joue,
c'est pas du tout pareil.
L'enfant regarde
et ça interrompt ses capacités.
Et là,
d'être dehors et de marcher,
pas d'être en poussette,
et de regarder le monde autour,
c'est important.
Se calmer,
plutôt avec un livre
qu'avec l'écran le soir.
-Maya a éteint les écrans
il y a quatre mois,
un sevrage difficile.
-Il faut tenir bon, demander
à la famille de faire pareil,
parce qu'elle progresse,
votre petite, je trouve,
au vu de votre histoire.
Le chemin est un peu long.
Comme on disait, ça prend du temps.
Musique douce
-Le lendemain,
Caroline Janvier
retrouve le docteur Dieu Osika
à son cabinet.
-Bonjour.
-Bonjour, docteur.
-Bonjour, madame Janvier.
Ca va bien ?
-Elle a fait partie de ceux
qui ont alerté la députée
sur les ravages des écrans.
Riley, 4 ans, et sa maman
consultent la pédiatre
depuis quelques mois.
Jennifer a eu un déclic
le jour où son fils
est entré en maternelle.
-J'ai compris qu'il y avait
un décalage avec les autres enfants.
Il ne parlait pas du tout.
Il ne savait pas jouer.
Il s'exprimait
qu'avec des cris.
C'était... Il était vraiment
à l'opposé des autres enfants.
-Vous imaginiez, madame,
que des écrans pouvaient faire ça ?
-Pas du tout,
sinon, j'en aurais jamais donné
à mon enfant.
Franchement, si c'était à refaire,
je le referais pas.
-Est-ce que vous trouvez
qu'on n'est pas
suffisamment informés
de ces choses-là ?
Vous auriez aimé le savoir ?
-Oui.
-D'accord.
Comment vous auriez aimé
qu'on vous le dise, ça ?
A la maternité ?
-Dès la maternité.
-Vous pensez
qu'on devrait dire "Attention"...
-C'est dans le carnet de santé,
mais je ne l'ai pas lu.
-D'accord.
Vous avez découvert ce problème-là
en voyant ce que ça crée
chez votre enfant
et en voyant le pédiatre ?
-C'est ça.
Là, il commence à s'en sortir
avec la motricité fine.
Tiens bien ton stylo.
-Oui, ça y est !
-Caroline Janvier propose d'alerter
dès la grossesse
sur le danger des écrans.
-Ce que je me dis,
c'est qu'il faut que nous,
on protège mieux vos enfants,
on vous informe mieux
et qu'on trouve les bons endroits
pour vous informer.
C'est la maternité,
c'est l'école,
c'est des campagnes
d'information...
Musique légère
-Et comme pour l'école,
il faut former
les professionnels de santé.
-Les externes et les internes
que je vois à l'hôpital
ne sont pas formés.
La médecine sociale
est extrêmement faible
dans leur temps de travail,
dans le programme.
Les médecins généralistes
sont encore moins formés,
alors que 80 %
des enfants en France
sont suivis
par les médecins généralistes.
Le temps de formation
sur les écrans,
il est égal à zéro,
quasiment.
Si on veut bien
se poser des questions,
se dire que nous vivons
dans un autre monde
qui n'a rien à voir
depuis quelques années,
peut-être que l'enfant
est impacté.
-Un monde où l'écran
est omniprésent,
même là
où on ne s'y attend pas.
-Quand on voit
qu'on a maintenant
des constructeurs de landaus,
de poussettes,
qui prévoient des petits inserts
pour mettre la tablette ou l'écran,
afin que le bébé soit exposé
en permanence,
on voit bien
qu'il y a un problème.
Merci, madame.
-Merci à vous.
-On a besoin de vous
pour convaincre les autres parents.
Continuez.
-Il n'y a pas de souci.
-Justement,
comment convaincre ces parents
qui passent à travers les filtres,
ceux qui ne fréquentent pas
les structures
de la petite enfance,
ceux qui ne voient que peu
le médecin.
Ce soir-là, Caroline Janvier
organise un temps d'échange
et de sensibilisation
aux écrans
avec des habitants
de sa circonscription.
-Les risques
de troubles primaires du langage
peuvent être multipliés
par six
en cas d'une exposition
trop importante.
Un enfant qui a
des troubles du langage,
ça va le mettre en difficulté
dans tous ses apprentissages.
-La députée leur soumet
l'une de ses mesures phares :
imposer un avertissement
sur les emballages
de téléphone, tablette
ou ordinateur pour informer
des risques
d'une surexposition.
-C'est le point sur lequel
j'ai eu des difficultés,
car il y a un bras de fer
avec les industriels qui disent
que ça sert à rien,
car les gens lisent pas.
Je dis : "Comme ça vous mettra pas
en difficulté, faisons-le."
-Il y a quand même un lobbying
qui est derrière.
Je sais que là,
vous avez entamé
une croisade
qui ne sera
peut-être pas facile.
-Pour moi, le vrai sujet,
c'est qu'en réalité,
on a minimisé
les dangers d'une surexposition
aux écrans.
Je fais parfois le parallèle
avec ce qui s'est passé
dans les années 80
avec l'industrie du tabac,
où vous aviez
les industriels
qui introduisaient le doute
sur l'impact de la consommation
de tabac sur la santé,
en disant : "On n'est pas sûrs.
Il y a d'autres effets."
Il y a un vrai sujet,
soit de méconnaissance totale,
soit de sous-évaluation
du danger.
Je vous invite à suivre
les travaux qui vont suivre
et les actions
qui vont être mises en oeuvre.
-Alors,
Caroline Janvier compte
sur une prise de conscience
collective.
-Oui, c'est un sujet.
Il faut s'en saisir.
Merci à tous.
Applaudissements
Je crois qu'il y avait
un consensus sur le fait
qu'il y a une information
qui est très inégale,
et qu'on a
quelques lanceurs d'alerte,
quelques parents
assez connaisseurs du sujet,
mais que malheureusement,
le doute profite
à la surexposition.
Il faut réguler ça
et dire que la santé prime
sur l'intérêt économique.
-Et dix jours plus tard,
en première lecture
à l'Assemblée nationale...
-L'exposition des enfants
de moins de 3 ans
est un poison pour eux.
C'est dangereux.
-L'exposition a des impacts
sur la santé des enfants.
-Sur le fond, nous sommes d'accord.
-L'Assemblée a adopté...
-...les députés ont adopté
à l'unanimité la proposition de loi
de Caroline Janvier.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...